ces images ont fait le tour de la
planète
le siège du congrès américain envahi par
une foule de manifestants
le jour où les parlementaires étaient
réunis pour confirmer la victoire de joe
biden une scène de chaos qui a marqué
les esprits alors qu'abidal sera
officiellement investi en tant que 46e
président des états unis le 20 janvier
la capitale américaine se barricade de
nombreux américains redoutent un nouveau
soulèvement et craignent pour leur
sécurité à la merde et je vis dans la
peur de ces gens
ces gens ont des armes non pas une seule
arme il amasse des armes
ils viennent avec il n'y a pas de
détecteur de métal pour entrer dans
washington donc même s'il ya un décret
qui dit que les armes sont interdites
dans la ville il n'y a aucun moyen de le
faire appliquer ces gens des centaines
d'armes je vis dans la peur fait
habituellement bondées avant la
cérémonie d'investiture
la ville de sept cent mille habitants
est quasiment déserte restaurants et
commerces fermés suite à la pandémie
bâtiment protégé par des planches pour
éviter tout dégât
une situation qui fait froid dans le dos
c'est la première fois que je viens
depuis plus d'un an en général il y a
des gens partout
là c'est très très calme la ville est
comme un fantôme d'elle-même pour cette
américaine
le contexte actuel pourrait logiquement
justifier que cette investiture se fasse
de manière virtuelle
je pense que ça devrait être virtuel
c'était dans son programme de tout
fermer d'éviter les rassemblements
je pense que la meilleure façon de
démontrer que c'est un aspect important
du programme c'est d'éviter qu'il y ait
une foule de gens ici le jour de
l'investiture
si pour l'instant aucun changement n'est
prévu
les risques restent tout de même présent
donald trump a annoncé depuis plusieurs
jours ne pas vouloir participer à
l'investiture
pas sûr que ses partisans en fassent
autant